all right i have a couple of quick
stories to briefly talk about this is an
interesting one it it is now appearing
that donald trump has been desperate to
appear on joe rogan's podcast and that
joe rogan has turned him down we're
going to look at a clip of uh rogan
himself explaining this there's a daily
beast article joe rogan reveals he's
rejected trump multiple times for
interview rogan recently declared his
support for ron desantis on tuesday he
said he's absolutely no trump fan and
has no desire to assist them in any way
shape or form
this was on a podcast with host lex
friedman and rogan talked about how
weird the trump era is going to be in
retrospect some of the reasons rogan
cited are not ones i agree with uh but
that's okay let's listen to what joe joe
rogan had to say about uh trump wanting
to be on his show by the way i'm not a
trump supporter in any way shape or form
i've had the opportunity to have him on
my show more than once i've said no
every time i don't want to help him i'm
not interested in helping
now one interesting question
is
whether such an interview
would be a good interview for someone
like joe rogan and his show because when
you think about the rogan format which
is
uh three hour conversations and i've
been on for two of them on a show
um
often in depth
and sort of flighty
non-sequential thinking
is not very conducive to those types of
conversations and this is what trump
does you ask him about one thing and you
say hey you know what
what's the deal with though you i heard
you like fast food
yeah well you know i uh kfc you know
they make it they make a tremendous bird
and but the thing is you know the
democrats and radical joe biden they
want to control everything not only did
he lose he wants to take away burgers
and i mean we just you just can't have
it and i said i would fix it i would fix
all of it i would fix tray
you know it's it's not he's not even
really able to have that type of a
conversation and you know the
speculation of trump with adult adhd or
whatever i think the guy just has no
idea what's going on in any serious
depth with any topic i think that's
really the explanation and trump would
ramble on and interrupt and interject
about the election stolen or whatever so
from like a conversational standpoint
i don't know how trump does
a three-hour conversation with rogan
that's not a praise or a criticism of
the format i think it's a great
it's great to have podcasts of all
different formats and the three hour
conversation is a great format for
people who can do it it doesn't seem to
me that that trump could do it now in
terms of rogan
doesn't want to help trump as i've said
before
i don't think there's any
like big mystery
about rogan
i think
rogan admits
he's not the most keyed into politics
and rogan to a degree is a chameleon of
sorts when i was on his show and i
espoused all of my left-wing ideas
joe agreed with almost everything i had
to say
and then when he has on you know whoever
from the right
he agrees generally with most of the
things they have to say he's had
disagreements that i've covered with
people like um
he's had disagreements with ben shapiro
on some things he's had disagreements
with candace owens you know
right-wingers in a sense
and to a degree i think that what's
happening with rogan is
he is um
when it comes to a lot of different
areas he is clearly on the left when you
get into the details i think he
genuinely is
i think he's also culturally
conservative a lot of the circles he's
now in
you know ufc and dana white
definite right wing uh bent there he's
now in texas and reportedly i think has
a relationship with the governor there
greg abbott who's an extreme right
winger
he's in this environment where there's a
lot of kind of de facto right wing
thinking and then like on desantis i
just think he's sort of confused i don't
even think rogan is aware that desantis
stands for the opposite of most of the
things rogan has espoused support for so
i don't think we need to get into this
thing of like ascribing
a significant morality to it i think
politics isn't rogan's main thing
and he finds common ground with almost
anyone he talks to
and while he is socially liberal to a
great degree
he's also in a culturally conservative
environment and that rubs off on him so
interesting for sure how much we glean
from it about anything in particular
other than trump's desperation to get on
rogan's podcast which is interesting uh
is probably not too too much
as many of you know i take my snacks
very seriously i avoid excess sugar and
junk food and so when i want something
sweet
i go to our sponsor monk pack monk pack
makes my favorite granola bars and nut
and seed bars if you're doing keto it
works just one gram of sugar or less
only two to three net carbs under 150
calories the flavors are delicious sea
salt dark chocolate that's my favorite
you've got your coconut cocoa chip
you've got your caramel sea salt the
texture the flavors this is a beautiful
granola bar and then you've got monk
packs nut and seed bars which are more
crunchy if you're craving something like
a crunchy chocolate candy bar
monk pack is the perfect thing to grab
instead same taste same experience none
of the carbs and sugars and calories
get 20 off your first order at
monkpack.com using the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below